it may be small but the mini has a big
place in british automotive history the
car began rolling off the assembly lines
in birmingham in 1959 as the austin
seven and the morris mini miner just six
years later in 1965 designer alec
izagonis personally handed over the keys
to the owner of the millionth mini the
car owed its success to its
revolutionary concept
christopher says compacts were a mess in
the 1950s there were two stroke engines
and four stroke ones engines in the
front and back front and rear wheel
drive it was anything goes until the
mini came and revolutionized things
in the early 1950s the ideal economy car
still seemed a long way off
in france the situant ii cv brought
mobility to the masses with its
two-cylinder air-cooled front engine and
front-wheel drive
in germany the rear-wheel drive bmw 600
had a two-cylinder boxer engine in the
back its front doubled as the front door
since 1945 volkswagen had producing its
robust beetle powered by a four-cylinder
boxer engine in the trunk
and renault gave its 4cv a water-cooled
four-cylinder inline engine also mounted
at the back
then along came the mini a traversely
mounted front engine with four cylinders
and front-wheel drive squeezing the
technology into a small space left lots
of room for passengers
our tester says the key was lightweight
construction with the mini everything
really is mini even in here mini comfort
many standard features and mini seats
there's not even a door handle just a
pole here to open it but all this
slashes the car's weight the mini weighs
barely 600 kilos so christoph says its
34 horsepower engine has more than
enough pep
austin claimed that on average the mini
accelerated 30 percent faster and used
10 percent less fuel than its
competitors it could go from 0 to 130
seconds and reach a top speed of 120
kilometers an hour but those figures
alone hardly explain how the mini became
the stuff of legend
christoph says the car has that famous
go-kart feel this is due to its small
wheels and low center of gravity as well
as the hydroelastic suspension which
keeps it from veering to the side on
corners so he says it's lots of fun
driving the mini on twisty roads
in the city too this agile little car
can maneuver through the smallest of
spaces although it's just three meters
in length the mini can seat four adults
for such a small car it's very spacious
inside kristoff says
but then he says the mini was always a
giant among small cars
everything possible was done to save
room for the interior
the four-cylinder engine is mounted
transversely with the transmission in
the sump
and the radiators at the left
but what christoph likes best is the
trunk
he says that while it doesn't offer much
room for luggage you can also put your
suitcase here on the tailgate and to
make sure you can still see it from
behind that license plate folds out too
christoph says this has been really well
thought out something he can't say about
all british-built cars
the mini is chock full of clever ideas
the door hinges and standing seams are
located on the outside thereby
increasing interior space and cutting
production costs
the car's tiny 10 inch wheels and
correspondingly small wheel arches are
space savers too
the sliding windows in the absence of a
regular dashboard also mean more room
for passengers
what they sacrifice and features is made
up for by the increased cargo space an
ample leg and head room
it's four cylinder engine with 848
centimeters of cubic capacity generates
25 kilowatts of power that's enough to
tool around the city or enjoy leisurely
drives in the country
almost 5.4 million minis have been
produced making it the top selling
british car of all time
the car has fans around the globe and as
love is blind they're willing to
overlook the mini's weaknesses
christoph says he has a few complaints
like the heating and ventilation which
don't work at all he says you really
have to stomp on the brakes and even
then they're not too responsive the air
box isn't terribly well synchronized
either and then there's the price the
mini cost over 5 000 deutsche marks in
germany over a thousand more than a vw
beetle
today a standard austin mini in good
condition cost between six and twelve
thousand euros but expect a fork over
three times that much for a sporty
cooper version but to experience the
fascination of the mini an entry-level
model will do
christoph says legend has it that
engineer alec izagonis came up with the
idea during dinner and sketched out the
design for the mini on the tablecloth
and napkins what he created was
essentially the blueprint for all modern
compacts and remains the standard to
this day so he says the mini is
definitely a milestone in automotive
history
the original mini was produced for 41
years from 1959 to the year 2000 and
little wonder this forerunner of the
modern compact is a truly timeless car